i don't know if uh english breakfast was
made in like south england or north
england yeah because in north england
they don't say lunch
we don't say the word lunch what do you
say dinner yeah they say dinner oh
that's right oh and supper it's
breakfast tea tea
when i was growing up i would be my mom
would be like oh i'd be like when's
dinner and that's like 12 o'clock and
then when when's tea which is it like
that's so weird you laugh what was that
[ __ ] face you just you just you just
made up a word like let's have i said no
tears
it's been around for i don't know how
long it's been around for actually
that's a good point look you made the
language i can't be mad
you guys skewed it you i i am assuming
it was it was bastardized into lunch
yeah maybe it was always dinner and then
americans were like no this is too
complicated
that's just a northern thing you know we
say lunch down in the south i wonder
which one who started what came first
which one changed what came first which
one's your dinner
basically it's lunch you know that comes
before dinner
checkmate when you look at the map what
side is like the like the colloquially
dumber side or like more rural not
necessarily a [ __ ] day
like in america definitely the north
are you trying to start a civil war
like who are the dumb idiots that
deserve nothing
because you rephrase it in a way that
makes you the hero and me the villain
he lives in the rich south yeah swirling
his martinis while i'm swirling my iron
brew infused with a shot of vodka i'm
just crying just trying to make it
through the winter you ever had an iron
brew no oh my god what's that that's a
oh wait you don't know home brews
it's a scottish drink and it's just it's
kind of popular up north it's this drink
that's filled with sugar it's awful it's
all has more sugar than curry i think
americans would love it because it's so
sweet yeah yeah well have you guys have
had root beer right yes i love you
really yeah
it's [ __ ] vile i gave it to connor he
hated it
it's like poor man's medicine i don't
know it just tastes like [ __ ] that's dr
pepper that's like what
nah dr pepper tastes too mediciney for
me that's that's what medicine tastes we
gotta we gotta get every soda and do a
soda tear list where you guys are still
here
let's go through it yeah one thing about
going back to like north and south
divides like a big debate in the uk is
where like even the the south
and the north begins because there's
this place uh called the midlands right
and i don't even think the midlands
exists you know because anything above
anything above london is the north to me
right no yeah does where where where
where does the north begin for uconn
it's a it's a lot it's literally been
like there's been studies on this it's
like a diagonal line
right where it's kind of cause it's not
like a everyone wish it was a horizontal
line but it's diagonal because you don't
want to throw whales in there well no
because whales would be considered north
right that's why it's diagonal yes if it
wasn't whales would be part of the south
no it would be probably part of the
north i'd imagine how still yeah which
part of wales
because like wales is kind of in the
middle right yeah so it's kind of i
don't know
what are the major cities in the south
or the north uh what like cardiff got
off south yeah which would be south yeah
i'm not from cardiff all right
i'm from the north you're from the poor
section yeah
again the poorer of wales which is all
poor
i'm from the poor
my man's struggling yeah i just can't
get i can't catch a break
and i didn't even get the documentary to
be on the welsh biggest youtuber
no w's from wales i literally can't get
it from wales even in wales
i think my favorite thing i've heard
about the midlands is who who are you
hanging out that said they went to
birmingham and they were like i
understand why they called it the
midlands
yeah i forgot who it was it was like
yeah i was like uh
i think it was one of my friends from
high school because he lives in the uk
now and he was like yeah i went to
birmingham the other day and i was like
why did you go to birmingham and he's
like i have a friend who lives in
birmingham and it's like it was pretty
mid i think that's why they're called
the midlands
man stoke from trenton
it's above birmingham i just looked
where it was yeah i thought it was like
in the middle
oh my god wait so birmingham is the
south no birmingham
midlands
although that's what people from
birmingham would say yeah like an hour
uh struggle trend is like an hour drive
from where i grew up
really yeah well it's a lovely town you
should go visit it with your family
you gotta smash tony yeah why was there
i don't even want to know
did you have a fish and chips while you
were there i haven't actually ever had
fish and chips in the uk oh
i refuse i don't think you guys would do
fries correct what the [ __ ]
your fries suck here wendy's bro come on
you have those fries were good but like
thick fries from like uh fat fat burger
that was terrible yeah yeah you guys
can't you guys can do like thick cut
fries no or chips but i also don't want
them i want them fried salty with a
bunch of msg and i want to feel like a
little tubbo guy that's what i enjoy
doing
it's a greedy endeavor when you even
attempt to eat fries i love the thick
fries though
i actually enjoyed the taste of potato
yeah
what
you're not eating it for oil and salt
okay unfortunately not yeah interesting
you know it depends on the mood mostly i
prefer like thin carp but you know
sometimes you just want a nice thick
bite of potato i want to think [ __ ]
yeah respect that yeah did you try any
other british food while you were there
no i tried to avoid generally
we had the tesco meal deal right tesco
meal deal goes hard yes very good uh and
i don't mind that but everything else
i didn't go to greg's once nando's i did
go to nando's but that's not british
food i mean we try to pretend it's
british food yeah because it's one of
the only things we can well like look
everything in britain we we take it from
another country and then just say it's
ours yeah that's cool that's been our
history for a very long time i guess
that you are the literal kings of that
yeah yeah
yeah because like in a lot of indian
restaurants they uh like serve chicken
tikka masala and that's that's a british
dish well scottish actually okay okay is
it um yeah
it wasn't invented in india it was
invented tikka tikka is like a ah a
scottish thing like the way of cooking
the chicken i see it's like a scottish
thing i don't know that's a scottish
dish so if you've ever had a chicken
tikka masala yeah when i go into the
indian restaurant that i local i'll say
this is scottish just so you know
just so you know but then like i think
like most indian restaurants in the uk
are run by bangladesh people anyway yeah
so i mean you're not even getting an
authentic experience it's close
it's like going to a chinese restaurant
here and ordering sweet and sour chicken
right yeah because that's not even
chinese food right if i think it's all
bastardized versions of the food that
would be palatable to the people who
want to consume it yeah
but surely it's wrong with that you like
you teleported any american to like
shinjin china and they went to like a
local eatery they'd be lost oh yeah
i like kung pao chicken like what's
going on here
man panda express looks different
is fantastic
uh i mean it hits it's right
yeah it's i think you're gonna be in the
right move for pandaria yeah yeah
because sometimes what is the right mood
it's the mood of [ __ ] there's nothing
else open
to it
or like a pizza or like anything like
greasy i just want like something and
you go to panda express for a non-greasy
food well i've only been like twice so
you know that says a lot i will say i i
do think sometimes the bastardization of
food is good
well yeah like i'm not going to say no
no
yeah amazing yeah i'm not going to say
no to a california role like that
it's an innovation in a way yeah i don't
think that's like the best ideas
bastardization of food though right
yeah some people would say it is like i
think there's an argument we made i mean
i i think the best argument i've heard
is i was like i can't remember like what
chef i was like watching but i know i do
believe you can cook food from any
culture that you want to and no no
recipes sacred the only the only time it
is actually offensive is just if it
tastes bad right yeah i agree you know
what but i do think there are people who
would be upset if you called a dish like
what it's called natively like if you
called it sushi but it was like some
amalgamation of fish in different things
that taste good but it's like you can't
call that sushi yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
you know i do get that where i've seen
like some people trying to cook thai
dishes and like i've seen like i've seen
some
uh there was this like reality tv show
on netflix where people from the uk
would try to like make their own
restaurants and pitch it like kind of
like uh
kind of like uh
sorry not kitchen no no kitchen
nightmares like shark tank like shops
meals yeah
i remember these two british blokes
tried to like pitch like opening a thai
restaurant in manchester
and so and so they were going about
their backstory and they were like yeah
you know i we firmly believe that you
don't you don't as long as you
understand the culture and you
understand the recipes and everything
that no recipe is sacred and i was like
yeah i agree with that you know i'm not
going to get patriotic to my own country
just because someone else wants to cook
it yeah and then they was talking about
their experience cooking thai dishes and
they were like yeah we've been to like
thailand for like two months and uh did
like a boot camp and that was it and i
was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's like
that's like the backstory of the two
guys who uh started outback steakhouse
oh really they'd never been to australia
supposedly and it's an australian
restaurant so because like i remember
the first time i went to an outback
steakhouse was on australia day god
forbid in japan of all places and my
friend was like yeah there's no bug
steakhouse right there we should we
should celebrate australia what a crazy
mashup of cultures to be eating in an
outback steakhouse an american-made
australian restaurant in japan yeah yeah
who is my japanese presumably japanese
chefs as well yeah yeah yeah
and i've never been to an outback
steakhouse i was like oh let's go in
it's it's supposedly australian right
yeah and immediately my eyes has glazed
over from all the [ __ ] boomerangs on
the walls and like the disney dudes
everywhere like i looked at the menu and
i'm like nothing
onions blooming onion is not australian
i'm sorry like
and i had fosters there i did i tried
fosters for the first time oh gosh in
japan yeah it tastes like awesome it's
awful it's [ __ ] horrible i'm like no
wonder they don't sell it in australia
yeah fosus has a single-handedly ruined
australian spear reputation yes i mean
australian beer still sucks ass but like
it's like fosters is yeah there's a
reason why they don't sell in australia
no one would drink that yeah it's like
like in the uk we have a our local beer
that's mass reduced is probably karling
and i'm so glad that you can only get it
in the uk or i've only seen it in the uk
because it tastes like piss right
because you had carling right did you
have darling yeah
that was horrible i think it's yeah it's
definitely uk let's let's have a look
before i think that's every country
though like we always release our worst
product but it's maybe the most
palatable because it's just water and it
gets you pissed drunk quick what would
you say is the worst american you're
gonna
was founded in 1840 by thomas carling at
london and upper canada uh in 1952
carling oh yeah there's a london in
canada that's right london
oh you thought it was
weirdly enough it's it's a canadian
company but they only sold it in uh the
uk it was first sold in the uk
is it only sold in the uk i don't know
so it's a uk beverage
so much good beer though that isn't
carly yeah we do we do we just
i um most of them actually comes from
the north actually you you guys you guys
make a good way of them i'll give you
guys there's a w there's a w
whales whales whales that's how you sell
whales we have good beer
it's very affordable as well it's like
half the price of london yeah massage
third that's the third time the price
yeah what do you think is the worst
us beer that you guys export a lot it's
all [ __ ] i mean it's like if you have
bud light you have natty light which is
terrible oh yeah
guys yeah yeah that sucks yeah
do you secretly love budweiser oh we did
a beer tasting stream once uh a blind
beer tasting stream from like beers from
all over the world and we thought
budweiser was like a joke
like budweiser like like normal
budweiser
i mean that's better that's a
full-bodied
it certainly doesn't make you look like
you have great tastes exactly
because especially we were like drinking
we're all like yeah german beer
definitely german beer is there a big
drinking culture in new hampshire
uh no big fentanyl culture though they
do a lot of fentanyl what's that that's
the like the it's the most lethal drug
in the world
yeah it's like what they
tie in with heroin and that's how people
die
huge opioid crisis in new hampshire is
it actually yeah they're bored they're
bored it's i mean it's less people in
new hampshire than like phoenix arizona
it's like one million maybe
you must be bored if you like can't even
like even turn to alcoholism you're like
no no i need something harder than
alcohol yeah we need to go further than
beyond
the american medical system has failed
america
but it's it's cool drugs man you're
losers
well you know new hampshire state motto
no what is it live free or die oh is
that actually yeah it's badass
and they'll inject that into their veins
[Laughter]
to my fellow new hampshire rights
i thought they each coasted a a good
drinking culture i thought they were
they were like all about drinking beer
and i think like boston boston's i mean
in general in the states they've relaxed
microbrewery laws so like you know
there's insane beer culture if you're
really into it like yeah i guess boston
makes sense because every second
bostonian is like yes i'm irish yeah
yeah they're they all really yeah that
is my biggest pet peeve of americans is
claiming like a european culture when
it's like you have zero attachment
outside of you took a 23 in me or your
parents told you like yeah we're irish i
think yeah that's that's my favorite
copium where i'm like oh so where is
your family from and they're like oh i'm
like one sixteenth irish yeah one
sixteenth i'm like that doesn't count
why do they try and hold on to that like
why is that something they they
gravitate to try and label them connor
it's not that cool to be just american
these days
i don't know if you've kept up
but like no one's kind of gonna be like
yo [ __ ] for real that's badass like why
why people still try and do it i think
it like it also ties into things that's
how it comes up it'll be like oh i can
drink all night i'm 15 irish
i don't think alcoholism just goes
through gymnastics no and of course it
doesn't but then it'll be like you know
be like oh i can't be in the sun too
long i'm 20 polish so like they just
have that and that's like they'll spout
their one fact this is like an rpg skill
tree yeah i've spent too much in a
strength i can't i can't do the agility
exactly but it's like your starting
stats and it's like it doesn't matter
you could spec anything you want as well
yeah yeah like i i'm like i'm like
southeast asian full-blooded southeast
asian i cannot [ __ ] handle the heat
at all yeah so obviously it's got
nothing to do with my genetics and
everything to do with my [ __ ]
upbringing right yeah yeah all [ __ ]
what is what is your
ethnicity background so like culturally
i'm very french
five percent irish
welsh baby uh i'm mostly uh my dad's
side is like all swedish and then my
mom's side's all spanish and they both
immigrated to america from there oh but
my mom first generation yeah i'm first
chad i'm the only person in my family
tree ever born in america wow but now
i'm hard-blooded murk in
through and through
my my blood's red white and blue
uh
but yeah everyone else like mostly
france and sweden's where they all live
now
and have you seen like that uh your
family in europe and stuff like that
yeah we used to go every summer so i
would spend like like a month in europe
and i was always like a pissy bratty kid
because i'd be like i want to be in
america and get a cake for my birthday
and hang out with my soccer friends and
i'd be like no you have to go on a like
a multi week where's my sunny d
you have to go to france and sweden and
experience cultures and i was like no
and i was such a brat i regret it
because i got we would go to france and
it'd be like like near nice like
beautiful
and and i'd be in the like my uncle's
house just watching naruto like
mainlining filler episodes and then
they'd be like oh come out let's go to
like the beach like pelevester floats
and i was like
yeah we spoke about this
i had the same thing my parents took me
all around yeah play games i hated that
they took me around and now i kind of
regret it but when i was a kid i was
like all i want to do is play pokemon
fire red like leave me alone mine was
pokemon ruby and watch naruto and
outside of that piss off and i don't
want to speak this stupid language speak
english to me i'd like go around hunting
for wi-fi
like my whole thing is the whole trip i
would just try and find wi-fi yeah that
would literally be it it was so hard
back then too oh yeah because there
wasn't like a starbucks or mcdonald's
that has free wi-fi for everyone yeah
yeah it was hard and then you'd have to
go and ask the staff really awkwardly
and they'd be like oh
we're in france we don't want to give
you anything yeah i would just like
stock up on games i'm like my game boy
and just like bring like a [ __ ]
rucksack f full of game cartridges
the week before i was supposed to go to
france i got a call after school had
ended from this girl and and she was her
name was alexis and she's like hey uh
racelyn which is another girl from my
class racelyn wants to date you and i
was like super uncomfortable and i'd
never like done that before so i was
like uh
i'm going to france
and she's like well yeah what like she
wants
she wants to like date you and like go
like you can date when you come back
yeah i was like
oh no i got to go to france
and i kept mainlining that and that's
how i got out of it that next year
racelyn got expelled permanently because
she showed up to school with a bunch of
knives she was very edgy oh wow she used
to show up with like about the gulf
guild championship she was goth girl gf
you showed up powdered sugar be like
it's cocaine
and then she shoved knives until she got
expelled but then i think she actually
became edgy because she tattooed 5150 on
her neck yeah which is the cop signal
for like crazy person on the loose
and she got it just big tattooed so i
could have dated her
what is helpful but i went to france who
could have had the ghost that she wasn't
like other girls